[Musique]
vous avez remarqué la rue aujourd'hui
les branchés mode sont partout de la
tête aux pieds il vit temps plein dans
leur époque dans le contraste est la
distinction reste larges pantalons
étroits noir et plus aux cheveux ras et
mèche pendante le banal et
l'exceptionnel réunit la vitrine de la
culture actuelle
[Musique]
les gens cherchent cherchent de plus en
plus personnalisés
et
de la coiffure a fait des progrès et de
créativité pour justement arriver à
répondre
ces gens qui veulent bien dans leur cour
ou qui ont chacun des environnements
différents
couper les cheveux maintenant par
jenny on se fait couper les cheveux
parce que parce que c'est important
d'être bien placé pour pouvoir vivre
mieux ou tous les jours que ce soit
qu'on les femmes nées de plus en plus
sera également pour les hommes
ce mercredi là dans un salon rennais on
venait se faire coiffer et coiffée
soi-même tout délire permis dans cette
création sur le cheveu pour le fun et le
look
m des pétards theekoye des beta 1 bêta
comme ça
au sur la tête avec la couleur et si
vous cherchez à créer en coiffant
c'était de faire des coiffures sympa on
apprend des trucs drôles avec une
couleur
dai a dû faire sur moi ça doit se voir
du super eagle couleurs ya le cas du
rose du bleu du vert va un plateau comme
ça sur la tête
on pourrait peut-être pas se passer
comme ça dans la rue mais enfin pour
aller en boîte ses 100 ans
c'est ce qu'ont cherché à faire
c'est important dans l'apparence
aujourd'hui la coiffure rue gagnent
d'argent il faut faire foi des supers
pétardé superbe facture des trucs qu'on
trouve pas toujours quoi ça change de
l'habitude une façon de se démarquer de
se sentir bien dans son corps aussi
et puis la coiffure c'est aussi la tenue
vestimentaire c'est une façon de vivre
aussi et c'est une façon de se sentir
bien parmi la société s ou façon aussi
d'écouter une offre à certains types de
musique
enfin la coiffure c'est tout et des
réponses utiles donc donc ça passe bien
utile pour l'apparence way pour la pense
surtout que pensent les filles qu'est ce
que j'en pense bah ça dépend des goûts
de la personne sur certaines pensent que
c'est très bien et donc trois bouts
fait trop punk tu m'as bien fait arriver
là ça va être bonne que ça dépend pas
requis pour être professeur et comme on
est tout le système de l'école c'est
très simple je veux pas me mettre en
fois avec certains copains qu'ils ne
sombrent moi si je pouvais je me
mettrais punk mais pour l'instant la
foresterie new wave c'est pas le mot qui
convient mais comme ça même idée dans
les fringues que l'on porte pour être
une star une star pour soi même un coup
fatal porté aux jeans classique
à moins d'être dans sa tête james dean
comptait beaucoup de lévis fermetures
éclair et tout mais maintenant on
retourne aux cinq sens et ça c'est
vraiment un phénomène quand même de mode
dont le 501 ça représentait james dean
marlon brando et c'est le premier jean
qui est vraiment existé et puis le jean
c'était peut-être une sorte de
l'uniformité
je pense que les jeunes vont chercher
autre chose est-ce qu'on va passer
avance aussi une nouvelle uniformité des
de la coiffure des pétards en fait tout
le monde en porte maintenant parce que
ça va évoluer
ça évolue toujours la mode c'est ça qui
fait l'originalité
vous n'êtes pas vous raser la tête par
exemple demain si c'est à la mode non si
je le sens seulement si je ressens pas
faut voir aussi ce qui va avec
l'individu aussi pour ça en ce moment ce
qui est bien c'est que chaque individu
pour adapter hier certains types de
vêtements à son cou à son corps poignet
et certains types de coiffeur à son
corps pourquoi être aussi faut être bien
les faux pas être ridicule
[Musique]